[Music]
hello everybody this is International
Master Sam Frankland and today I would
like to go over the next installment in
my series on the best and we've ever
played and this one was between
Grandmaster mikhalev ski play and white
against the Grandmaster steffanson
playing black and this was a
particularly hard one for me to rank
because uh mikhalev skis brilliant idea
here I think was a lot better than some
of the ideas played in the higher games
the ones that I ranked higher than this
one but Nicholas he also a messed up
later in the game in meltingly he ended
up losing so it was kind of a tough game
for me to rank but I think fifth is a
fine choice and without further ado I'll
get you started on what happened so
mikhalev ski here is playing white and
in this position he has an extra pond
but black has some annoying activity his
seasick spawn is weak and the bishop on
g3 is pretty passive so although this
move right here I wouldn't say is like
the amazing one he certainly had the
amazing one planned when he played this
he played a a five check which is a very
strong move his idea is he wants to
deflect the enemy King if the King goes
back to a7 then the black B pawn is
easily held at bay by the rook because
the King can't support it after move
like Bishop to h2
what's plan is to play Bishop g1 f3
Bishop d6 well it looks that a very
pleasant position and a dangerous sea
pawn so this would probably be a bit
unpleasant for black although okay maybe
this was his best option because in the
game he took on a five and now
Michalowski are one of the most
beautiful forcing sequences I've ever
seen and it started out with the
temporary exchange sacrifice rook takes
a lot of course black has to take back
and now e six with a dual threat one is
taking on f7 and then having these two
pawns which will quickly finish the game
and the other is fish
to see seven check so if if black had
decided to try to play some some some
sort of like rugby FA to defend against
both threats after Bishop to see seven
the King can't go to before of course
because after check we lose this rook
King goes to a four and now a strong
move Bishop e5 attacking this rook on a
AJ excuse me and I think after Bishop e5
rook g8 Bishop d6 which is another
strong move what's winning the reason he
needed to play Bishop e5 was because in
this position if the rook or on h8 why
it might have some issues but here after
simple heat six of seven the rook is
hanging so this would be like if I go
back to um here if I had played vision
we hope you enjoyed this video demo from
chess comm subscribe today to finish
this video and get unlimited access to
our full video library your membership
also includes access to chess mentor the
most advanced interactive training tool
available anywhere you'll also get full
access to the opening Explorer tactics
trainer and much much more so sign up
today and get serious about improving
your game
[Music]